yeah here we go welcome to this video
shooting hi wo 8 and we're in the
opening challenge so what am I going to
play against him I'm not allowed to play
my normal stuff hmm ok let's try the
Dutch try man go for the stone wall him
ok so he's putting the knight on f3
voluntarily which is not a bad thing I
think it's just that night h3 is a
different option that I think is some
some way more challenging ok so I'm
trying to pretend to know what I'm doing
him but not sure how how good this work
so interesting timbira groups there
night night here probably the first and
if i go bishop h5 you probably goes
night f form
hmm jump okay you put this on the board
first now nitey 5d takes is wrong yeah
that is wrong if I go naija 52 f seven
maybe yeah just too can I do this try to
trade off only five like that I'm kind
of really inventing stuff about it I
have played the Stonewall years ago once
in a while with black but I really don't
have any detailed knowledge or
experience with this so it's just taking
their which may oh ok I can do that but
is it so bad i don't know let's take and
now night f7 so he plays a little bit
like vision I did yeah I'm taking this
Bishop okay's even allowing this trade
this should be okay right don't think
that I have I'm having any particular
problem him
so f4 f4 Teague's not i know i can go fo
actually if he takes it 26 the tempo on
the rook so i get with son overlooked
that one okay it's still it's still it's
still interesting it's still interesting
yeah and i will look that of course
quincy wanna overlooked bit of a shame i
think i had a really good position that
with the night against the stupid bishop
wyd special bungee to really is a bad
piece them and now i know kind of helped
in bellagio by giving giving away the
pond so here and then somewhere age 64 g
5 or g5 no let's do this let's start
with this the problem is g5 he will tape
player form so he has two airports
I'm not threatening anything him and
yeah what a shame I was heeded if I
spoiler position them it was really ok a
g5 is not not helping at all
thinking of getting the night back 2d 2d
six then to f5 maybe yeah okay I
couldn't couldn't really care about nine
important pawn their on a4a five
Queen age 4 is not working unfortunately
so I want to go to f5 anyway over the
night and I think I'm going to do I'm
going to manage that
Jeff white oh that's surprising I mean
not that it is bad or anything but I
didn't expect that giving me the F for
pawn down that seems like more activity
than I deserve but maybe there is
something concrete happening to me
likessee 5 45 or something night oops
come on night here all night lagi fiver
night is pretty well placed on g5 do
this yes and then I'm going going if you
55 something better than taking the
immediate you five maybe that that gives
me a pawn down maybe okay okay it will
only when I'm going to help helping me
there anyway and I can take click on the
form porn chicks
okay let's do this it's not if he takes
on c6f Queen you one check so that
that's it's a that's a very simple trick
but at least it is a trick that said I
got more activity than I deserved maybe
h5 has an idea for me to have King age 7
and being able to move the King away on
some checks I don't I don't really think
that after move like Quincy for I have a
decent reply it takes ok Queen f7 maybe
ok this one so it's probably not the
best possible continuation but I have 30
seconds
yeah i think i actually spoil some
opportunities there while you certainly
was winning heave and load he allowed
some things check check queen of three
years this is a thread on draw let's
keep that check oops check okay check
yeah you got your point here black
resins jam that was totally unnecessary
and he allowed me allowed me really a
lot here taking a four and stuff but
probably it is it still it's too good
simply even this this bogus moves didn't
didn't kill his position now for a
stupid here yeah he black has a really
good position here it's just I'm totally
fine on the queenside yeah with this a 5
and so on Lucas misplace the bishop is
bad nakia is just better a little bit
better it's just a matter of how much
better I am not even better computer
gives me a slight advantage which is
probably fair but therefore is stupid it
just bland as a pawn essentially
overlooked Quincy one simply I thought
it was a clever trick using this
unprotected rook but um it's not a not a
good idea I should do this actually
maybe have this is the other way round
if she goes Quincy one now I have
different options I can for example just
put the Queen on before being an
annoyance in yeah here I'm just better
just bad
exposition a stupid human I just play
displayed this too crooked I like the
idea but i didn't i didn't see Quincy 18
here I'm just I'm just struggling up on
down and have no combination ya hear
that it was a bit shaky for white but
the comp never gives me anything
substantial so very sport very spot a
really nice position there I think the
way you played that with all the traders
leading nowhere and jam bit of a shame
ok well thanks for watching